[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie chez la
grande joie d'être en présence de Julie
Andrieu bonjour Julien
et on est c'est benjama Trottin au
restaurant l'Italie avec ça il a la
gentillesse de nous accueillir sur sa
magnifique terrasse et on est un peu
comme là-bas
exotique
et du coup ça tombe à pic puisque Julie
sort à nouveau livre qui s'appelle pasta
70 recettes pour en faire tout un plat
une pourquoi pas
alors d'abord nous c'était vu la
dernière fois pour a comme astuce Un
livre un livre de bonne copine j'ai
envie de dire c'est vraiment j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes généreuse
vous aimez donner non mais ça se sent
vous aimez transmettre vous aimez donner
vous êtes pas la garder vos petits
secrets ben non non c'est mon métier
s'épanouir autrement qu'en étant mère au
foyer femme au foyer bon elles ont fait
cette ce combat elles ont mené cette
lutte et elles nous ont permis
aujourd'hui de remettre pour nous
tranquillement en se disant que je peux
concilier être à la fois voilà une maman
épanouie et puis en même temps cuisiner
et pourquoi pas travailler pour ceux qui
qui le font qui choisissent de le faire
mais donc voilà moi j'ai été
effectivement élevé plutôt aux produits
industriels et mon enfant s'était nourri
de beaucoup d'autres bonnes choses et
d'autres bonnes valeurs et donc il a
fallu que je construise mon savoir
culinaire toute seule donc j'ai eu
effectivement la chance d'être assez
vite adopté par un éditeur qui était
également critique gastronomique donc
j'ai commencé à goûter parce que moi
j'aimais écrire donc je me suis exprimée
à travers l'écriture et puis ça m'a fait
mon oeil déjà et fait mon palais et puis
très vite j'ai voulu cuisiner et là je
me suis rendu compte que dans les livres
on avait des recettes mais quand on y
connaissait pas grand chose comme moi il
manquait beaucoup de choses en fait il
manquait même l'essentiel justement ces
petits trucs ces petits tours demain que
les chefs tiennent pour acquis et qui ne
sont pas toujours donc c'est vraiment là
où je me suis glissé dans cette brèche
voilà en me disant finalement n'importe
qui peut se mettre à cuisiner j'engage
même ce qui ne savent pas qui n'ont pas
reçu cette transmission comme moi à le
faire on tâtonne bien sûr on va faire
des erreurs on va apprendre de nos
erreurs comme dans tous les domaines
mais enfin c'est bien d'être un peu pris
par la main par quelqu'un qui a un peu
d'avance et qui en plus qui parle votre
langage parce que moi j'essayais
d'éviter la terminologie des chefs la
rhétoriques compliqués tous les métiers
en ont une mais là c'est vrai que quand
on démarre on est content de pas
entendre parler de voilà foncer son
moule chinoiser sa sauce pareil
du coup bah ce livre rebelote enfin pas
ça vous avez des origines italiennes et
oui voilà oui oui même j'avais une
grand-mère italienne on voit d'ailleurs
je pense qu'on a cette photo
parce que ma famille était réduite à ma
mère et ma grand-mère donc estimant
c'est voilà la place était importante et
cette grand-mère était d'origine
italienne elle était arrivée avec ses
parents en France dans son jeune âge et
c'était installé dans le sud de la
France et elle y est restée toute sa vie
mais elle a gardé des liens très forts
avec avec la culture mais avec sa
famille aussi que je continue à voir
d'ailleurs
c'est Rome très vise l'origine c'est
vraiment très vise et après ils ont
bougé de Trévise jusqu'à Rome et Milan
et donc j'ai retrouvé des cousines et
c'est très touchant maintenant je parle
en italien
mais en revanche c'est vrai que par la
cuisine qui ne s'intéresse pas la
cuisine italienne et là j'ai pu renouer
un peu avec mes racines italiennes et
puis bon j'adore les pâtes je crois
qu'on les aime tous on s'en est aperçu
quand on vous suit sur Instagram on a la
pastèque du mercredi alors vous faites
ça pour vous pour faire plaisir à vos
enfants et pour vous faire plaisir aussi
à vous et à vos amis tous les mercredis
on est une nouvelle recette de pâtes
absolument fabuleuse alors ça va du plus
simple au plus original ou plus
compliqué enfin donc vous nous les avez
compilés
il y en a qui sont un peu plus raffinés
qui pourraient effectivement trouver
leur place dans un dîner un peu chic
mais par ailleurs c'est vrai que les
pâtes ça paraissant un peu comme
l'omelette vous voyez c'est recette on
se dit tout le monde peut le faire et
qui relève quand même là aussi de tours
de main qui font vraiment la différence
et finalement c'est faux sont enceintes
ça peut vite se rater très vite c'est
même le plus souvent raté je dirais en
France en tout cas dur alors pas pas ici
mais
la plupart des Français cuisinent la
sauce qui cuisent les pâtes sur cuise
les pâtes les mettre dans un plat après
les avoir égoutter et verse la sauce
dessus ce que les Italiens ne font
jamais puisqu'on en général à 80% on
verse les pâtes dans la sauteuse dans la
casserole où on a fait la sauce et on
finit la cuisson des pâtes qu'on a donc
égouttées on a gardé un peu d'eau de
et on finit la cuisson dans la sauce à
l'exception des sauces crues comme le
pesto par exemple ou les fameuses les
fameuses pâtes à la tomate crue qu'adore
votre fils c'est vrai qu'ils vont
forcément pas dans la poêle mais
néanmoins on va toujours mélanger les
pâtes dans un plat idéalement dans la
casserole qui sera encore chose et qu'on
aura donc vidé après les avoir égouttés
et de façon à garder la chaleur en
mélange jamais la sauce dans le plat
d'abord c'est pas joli parce qu'on va en
mettre partout
mais ce qui est normal il faut savoir
aussi que les pâtes refroidissent très
très vite c'est vrai alors vous avez
parlé d'une notion que je trouve
j'écoutais une interview que je trouve
très poétique là la durée de vie d'un
plat j'avais oublié que vous travaillez
beaucoup vous interviews c'est
sympathique vous êtes mignonne non c'est
vrai c'est pas toujours le cas
Jean-Marie hamac qui était un immense
chef qui était un des maîtres d'ailleurs
d'Alain Ducasse qui n'est plus de ce
monde et qui était un au bord de lait et
Jean-Marie un jour m'a servi un Pula
magnifique d'ailleurs je me souviens
c'était des un tartare d'aubergines et
de d'artichaut et il m'a dit dépêche-toi
de le manger parce que effectivement il
ne va pas respirer très longtemps et il
avait tellement raison c'est vrai que le
plat il a une ouais il a une vie il y a
un moment où il se passe de
d'apogée en fait de ces saveurs de sa
texture de sa chaleur de sa température
et si on discute alors bon ça se passe
pas deux secondes près mais enfin si
vraiment on oublie le plat du coup il
sera tout d'un autre monde voilà tout à
fait donc c'est pareil pour les pâtes
quand on voit les Italiens chez eux ils
regardent l'heure de trucs de cuisson
ils sont à cheval mais comme c'est pas
permis ils font goûter à tout le monde
et tout enfin c'est une affaire d'état
on attend les pâtes les pâtes
n'attendent pas bah voilà c'est ça
exactement et alors le risotto aussi ah
bah le risotto oui alors
justement le risotto il faut pas que ce
soit trop cuit en général on dit que
c'est 30 minutes et de plus
vous allez nous faire un livre sur le
risotto parce que j'ai des lacunes là
alors ce livre donc 70 recettes de pâtes
à l'orée il y en a qui sont quand même
un petit peu un petit peu bizarres moi
j'ai trouvé que celle au poireaux
noisettes sirop d'érable d'où ça sort
cette recette et au gros sel gris
c'est de nous raffiné vous le prenez à
Guérande l'île de Ré où vous voulez a
priori mais non il a plus de goût et
plus de minéraux alors là c'est vraiment
sorti de de mon esprit et puis surtout
de mon placard souvent les passes alors
les places donc il y a des inventions
bah oui bien sûr il y en a toujours des
inventions quand je fais la carbonara
j'invente pas grand chose si ce n'est
que mon tour demain
vous savez les légumes se marient bien
avec le sucre oui les légumes confits
caramélisés ça marche bien alors c'est
vrai j'ai fait une émission Canada
et qui met du sirop d'érable partout
je me somme enfin j'en ai pas partout en
revanche mais avec les poireaux ça
marche très bien puis vous avez vu que
les poireaux ils ont ils ont un sucre
naturel et quand ils sont bien confis
ils viennent caramélisés donc j'ai voulu
accentuer ça et puis contre avec le sel
pour ce côté un peu caramel beurre salé
et puis ça marche bien dans la pâte mais
selon moi mais oui
et quelle forme de pâte vous nous mettez
avec ça alors
je crois que c'était des Batel longue
parce que le poireau
je les ai pas tout en tête je me
souviens de la combinaison de sauce
après quelle pâte spontanément le
poireau ça dépend comment on le taille
en même temps mais je sais plus tu es
pas très grave on regardera et alors ce
que vous dites aussi c'est que la forme
de pâte on l'a choisi en fonction de la
sauce voilà oui
il y a beaucoup d'Italiens qui vous
disent qu'effectivement une pâte une pas
jusque là on va dégoûter les gens aussi
des pâtes tout savoir 50 variétés de
pâtes en fonction de la saison et des
ingrédients qu'on a sous la main mais
oui globalement il y a des sauces qui
sont mieux mises en valeur par certaines
formes de pâtes c'est d'accord bon bah
ça c'est pas assez écrit alors qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette mouche qui vous
a-t-il piqué la vodka ah oui c'est vrai
que votre cas partout parce que
traditionnelle je sais pas si elle
remonte très loin mais il y a une
recette italienne qu'on va trouver dans
des restaurants italiens de pâtes à la
crème vodka et tomates ça alors et je
trouve que c'est une combinaison qui
marche bien tout en sachant que je
n'aime pas la vodka déjà et donc j'ai
voulu aller plus loin et j'ai goûté un
jour une pâte à Venise d'ailleurs une
pâte qui était cuite avec une sauce
pareil une sauce tomate et servi avec un
petit choc de Bloody Mary et donc si je
n'aime pas la vodka je n'aime pas le
Bloody Mary mais j'ai trouvé que le
petit shot dont il me disait il faut le
verser au dernier moment sur les parcs
là ça rendait quelque chose de très
intéressant et un peu comme le gravlax
qu'on va mariner souvent avec un petit
trait de vodka et ça apporte une
amertume et ça va contribuer à liquéfier
un peu la sauce qui est toujours
tendance à se sécher au bout de quelques
minutes et donc voilà j'ai trouvé en
fait c'était surtout pour le geste pour
cette idée d'un poil de cocktail dans
les pâtes c'est rigolo un poil de folie
quoi trop dingue bon bah alors j'ai
compris
tout ça alors moi j'ai des questions
un peu bêtes mais tant pis j'y vais
alors carbonara crème fraîche ou pas
crème fraîche alors si vous voulez
fâcher les Italiens vous mettez de la
crème on veut pas les fâcher mais alors
moi je n'en mets pas parce que on m'a
expliqué qu'on n'en mettait pas bon
maintenant entre nous ce que je n'ai pas
mis dans le livre c'est que un tout
petit trait de crème à la fin
ça ne nuit pas forcément mais c'est vrai
que je le fais rarement mais j'ai
remarqué que pour les enfants
parce que c'est vrai que le One Shell et
qu'on a l'habitude d'utiliser est un
donc c'est la Bajou de cochon séché
c'est un goût fort donc quand je le fais
pour les enfants je disais que la tenue
un peu ce côté charcuterie un peu
puissante mais voilà c'est plutôt sous
cet angle là mais la vraie carbone ne
contient pas de crème c'est sûr et
encore moins lardons hola oui et alors
vous nous dites un truc qui est très
intéressant c'est que sur les paquets de
pâtes les modes d'emploi de temps de
cuisson en France sont plus longs qu'en
Italie oui clairement
avoir des pâtes trop cuite donc
attention messieurs dames ne croyez pas
ce qu'on vous dit oui alors parfois je
vous dirais même que les pâtes
italiennes les temps de cuisson des
pâtes italiennes vraiment
traditionnelles qu'on va acheter chez
les chez l'épicier italien sont même un
peu en dessous parfois moi je les
égoutte à autant dit je les goûte et là
c'est très très croquant donc finalement
la conclusion c'est goûter les bruits
moi je mets quand même mon petit timer
la
pour avoir
une jauge et puis une minute avant je
goûte et parfois je laisse une minute de
plus ouais mais c'est vraiment à chacun
selon son moi j'ai habitué mes enfants
et maintenant c'est eux qui me challenge
et qui me disent maman elles sont trop
cuites tes pâtes
mais ils ont pris l'habitude et c'est
vrai que c'est agréable d'avoir cette
main et en plus si paraît que c'est
beaucoup plus digeste et que l'indice
glycémique est plus bas donc est-ce
qu'on veut bon et alors juste pour finir
salade de pâtes ou passer salade de
pâtes parce que vous savez qu'on est à
Versailles oui et bah ça et on fait des
grandes salades et des grandes balades
de pâtes alors est-ce que vous êtes pour
je connaissais pas bientôt je vais faire
un livre sur la patate chaude alors
c'est ça en fait le prochain thème pour
être dans le sujet de Versailles
ben non alors c'est vrai que je suis pas
très salade de pâtes mais c'est
bien plus naturellement
pas forcément mais je reconnais qu'il
m'arrive en revanche comme je ne jette
rien de principe s'il me reste des pâtes
les réchauffer elles sont souvent trop
cuites
pour les déshydratés pour les réhydrater
un petit peu il faut mettre de l'eau
donc dans ces cas là parfois on en fait
des salades il y aura il suffit de
rajouter quelques feuilles de roquettes
un petit peu d'huile de l'huile de
l'huile et de l'huile et voilà ça peut
se transformer en salade mais c'est vrai
que non non c'est un sujet à creuser
vous avez raison vous avez pointé une
faille
dites-moi vous avez le virus du
maraîchage parce que votre émission bon
le livre on en a déjà assez parlé parce
que bref le dédicace à la suite quand
même
le samedi
qui est installée
magnifique très lumineux donc samedi 24
vers 16h 16h30 dans ces heures alors du
goûter vous avez donc votre émission
France 3 le carnet de Julie voilà
après vous avez attrapé le virus du
maraîchage ou je me trompe c'est vrai
j'étais hier encore dans le Mor pour un
tournage pour les potagers de Julie
c'est un légume une ville ou qu'est-ce
qu'on pratique ouais alors le principe
c'est surtout d'apprendre d'apprendre à
cultiver ses légumes ce que je ne savais
pas faire la même démarche de la cuisine
finalement voilà j'ai démarré en
affirmant
pourquoi pas que je ne savais rien je ne
savais pas faire pousser mes carottes et
quand on fait de la cuisine depuis 25
ans c'est quand même un problème et en
même temps j'ai toujours vécu en ville
et donc j'ai fait appel à une maraîchère
qui elle aussi était une citadine qui
s'est reconvertie comme beaucoup jeunes
maraîchère le laperrier et qui m'a
appris à planter à semer à faire mes
plans à faire mes semis d'où l'émission
d'où l'émission je pars en France
rencontrer des jardiniers amateurs mais
néanmoins souvent passionné et très
érudit qui chacun ont une approche du
jardin différente c'est là qu'on apprend
plein de choses encore vous allez faire
comme avec les chefs et puis on
rencontre
et le faire à ma sauce
avec vous c'est du vécu c'est vivant et
on apprend plein de choses choses et
vous avez d'ailleurs un magazine à
croquer oui qui sera tous les combien
tous les trimestres tous les trimestres
et qui va sortir bientôt là pour l'été
là
[Rires]
ça va tomber complètement à place là non
non mais c'est quoi la ligne éditoriale
de ce magazine et bien c'est une bonne
question
l'éditeur est venu me voir en me disant
on voudrait faire un magazine autour de
vous votre travail parce que c'est vrai
que j'ai une approche assez plurielle de
la cuisine
et donc je dis c'est une drôle d'idée et
je n'ai pas le temps et puis finalement
ils ont su me convaincre d'accord là
comme je l'ai absolument aucun caractère
non mais bon ils m'ont dit écoutez carte
blanche donc c'est une charge de travail
importante parce que contrairement à ce
que peut-être d'autres font moi je
contrôle tout j'écris tout un jeu il y a
des journalistes qui écrivent avec moi
mais disons que vraiment je passe à mon
tamis tout ce qui est dans ce magazine
et ce sont que mes recettes on n'a pas
l'épuiser que ce soit sur Internet ou on
les racheteurs donc voilà la ligne
éditoriale c'est ça ce sont mes recettes
je comprends sous tous les angles et à
toutes les saisons et dernière question
une collection de tabliers ah oui c'est
vrai mais ça fait un moment ça oui mais
bon on en parle c'est chouette bah oui
on en parle la collection de tabliers
entièrement fait maison avec des tissus
pratiquement à 80% français parce qu'il
y en a pour hommes il y en a pour homme
il y en a pour enfants
bien sûr et il y a surtout des tissus
jacquards magnifiques et je peux vous
dire qu'ils sont assez peu cher parce
que justement je ne gagne pas d'argent
là-dessus je suis en train de me dire il
va falloir que ça change mais on se
refait pas j'ai envie qu'il soit
accessible j'ai envie voilà claquer 100
euros pour acheter un tablier et donc
c'est des belles pièces originales en
France et tout de suite voilà qui sont
effectivement les tissus sont français
la maison de veau de très beaux
jacquards et donc c'est un peu ma
danseuse mais c'est très bien comme ça
oui mais on en a et puis on la pour la
vie oui exactement
un état d'esprit une philosophie un mode
de vie très bien un grand merci Julien
Drieu merci d'avoir trouvé le temps et
puis merci merci
bravo pour ce livre qui donne faim et
envie de cuisiner sans stress en plus je
crois en toute détente
à bientôt merci à bientôt
[Musique]